[Musique]
Charles Rodwell bonjour bonjour alors
nous sommes dans votre bureau de jeunes
nouveau député de la population puisque
vous avez été élu en juin Verdier député
de la première séquence des désillus
c'est un petit bureau d'ailleurs c'est
marqué c'est pas Versailles exactement
il n'est pas encore tout à fait habillé
non plus seulement parce que c'est une
début de législature mais il le sera
bientôt un peu plus on est ici au soin
rue de l'Université juste en face du
Palais Bourbon et c'est un grand plaisir
c'est très fonctionnel et puis je suis
entouré de mes collègues donc c'est
c'est un grand plaisir mais on voit
voilà c'est pas non plus on parle des
heures de la République c'est plutôt
dans les ministères que dans ces murs là
qui sont plus fonctionnels que ces
blaireaux sont très fonctionnels donc on
est vraiment à proximité les uns des
autres ce qui est très pratique pour
l'échange notamment et je pense qu'on va
en parler c'est vraiment une législature
sur le qui va être fondé vraiment sur le
dialogue si on va passer et de ce point
de vue là c'est c'est extrêmement
pratique ce d'autant que j'ai remarqué
depuis le début de cette législateur
qu'on passe du temps ici
et donc c'est un vrai plaisir alors on
va revenir évidemment sur votre élection
au mois de juin dernier de toute façon
63% à peu près des suffrages au deuxième
tour vous êtes élus député quel était
votre sentiment le jour vous avez
pénétré pour la première fois alors pas
pour la première fois vous avez déjà
pénétré parce que vous étiez conseillé
de Bruno Le Maire notamment mais en tant
que député dans dans ce palais Bourbon
parce que vous avez le sentiment est-ce
qu'on a le sentiment à ce moment-là de
vivre un moment d'histoire quoi
c'est un moment de très grande émotion
la première fois qu'on rentre dans
l'hémicycle en plus comme je faisais
partie du secrétaire d'âge du donc les
secrétaires ce sont les six plus jeunes
députés qui arrivent en dérive vous avez
26 ans maintenant je crois voilà c'est
ça
que vous avez été élu exactement voilà
et donc en fait on rentre en dernier et
lorsqu'on rentre dans cette hémicycle
plein avec une ambiance
très particulière parce que il y a 577
députés qui sont présents plus les
huissiers les journalistes au dessus le
public dans un hémicycle qui finalement
en fait assez petit qui est parait
beaucoup plus petit que lorsqu'on est à
la télévision qui est très bruyant pas
nécessairement on parle beaucoup des
invectives mais c'est un espace où il y
a certes des invectives mais surtout un
espace dans lequel on construit dans
lequel on bâtit la loi ensemble et donc
ce moment d'émotion il est vraiment
fondé sur deux choses un le sentiment de
vivre ses premiers instants donc député
en tant que législateur et de deux on
peut pas s'empêcher de penser
à la cinquantaine de personnes qui m'ont
aidés
c'est une élection qui est un peu
particulière qui est pas pareil que
l'élection municipale ou on est 5 ans
mais on est 50 à se battre pour
remporter ou conserver en tant qu'équipe
là ce sont 50 personnes qui se sont
engagées pour ma suppléante et moi jour
et nuit et ça de ce point là c'est
formidable alors dans ces premiers mois
de législature
qu'est-ce qu'il vous faut vous le plus
surpris et qu'est-ce qu'il faut
peut-être vous êtes moins surpris
alors ce qui va le plus surpris je veux
dire ouais en plus de au-delà de Bruno
Le Maire j'ai travaillé ici à
l'Assemblée nationale avec Franck
je trouve que le fonctionnement du début
de cette législature
et très différent par rapport à ce que
j'ai vu connaître d'un œil un peu plus
de
collaborateurs parlementaires
on est vraiment dans le dialogue alors
oui les médias mettent beaucoup en avant
les inductives les moments de conflit
les oppositions mais si on a réussi à
faire passer la loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat si on a réussi à faire passer le
projet blote finance rectificatif
permettant justement de financer ces
projets de loi c'est aussi parce qu'on a
su trouver des accords avec des groupes
d'opposition
et moi c'est ça qui m'a marqué c'est
l'esprit dans le fond de se dire on va
essayer de construire la loi en son
bourse pas toujours facile alors on a
échoué c'était peut-être plus simple
quand on parle de pouvoir d'achat enfin
des choses où on peut trouver des
consensus puisque sur des sujets sur
lesquels on va peut-être arriver
maintenant c'est à dire le budget
c'est-à-dire peut-être la question
d'énergie peut-être la réforme des
retraites aussi peut-être il peut y
avoir aussi plus d'opposition au
frontale moi j'ai le souvenir au
lendemain de du deuxième tour des
législatives
tout le monde y compris une bonne part
d'entre nous disons on n'arrivera pas à
gouverner oui on n'arrivera pas à faire
voter les gens résultat on a même si à
faire passer même il y a une forme
on est majoritaire on est majoritaire
mais il y avait un vrai questionnement
sur notre capacité à gouverner et je
crois qu'on l'a montré dans cette
première dans cette toute première
partie de législature et de quinquennat
qu'on avait les moyens de gouverner et
donc là à cette rentrée on explique que
on arrivera pas à voter le budget qu'on
arrive à faire passer aucune loi mais on
l'a prouvé avant l'été qu'on arrive à
trouver le consensus pas des accords
avec des accords sur des textes qui
évoluent mais on arrive à trouver le
consensus donc c'est peut-être le petit
missme de la jeunesse mais si on a
réussi à le faire avant l'été il y a pas
de raison qu'on n'arrive pas à le faire
après l'été est-ce que vous êtes dessus
justement qui disent au fond c'est vrai
que en France parce qu'on est habitué à
des majorités pléthoriques et donc c'est
souvent le modèle souvent dit regretter
d'ailleurs que le Parlement soit une
chambre d'enregistrement là il faut
apprendre cette culture de dialogue
cette culture de la négociation qu'on
n'a pas tellement qu'on a peut-être un
peu oublié en français et est-ce que
vous vous dites peut-être que finalement
cette majorité relative je parle de
votre point de vue c'est peut-être un
mal pour un bien en fait je pense que on
l'a eu cette culture du consensus en
France
quand on regarde l'histoire de la
Troisième République oui même de la
quatrième
et la version en plus du calendrier donc
tout à fait
on peut regretter le niveau des extrêmes
aujourd'hui dans l'assemblée
de voir l'état de notre situation
politique de ce pays mais dans le fond
aujourd'hui on a une assemblée quand on
calcule le résultat des législatives sur
peut-être le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle on voit que finalement
cette assemblée elle ressemble beaucoup
à l'état de l'opinion en France
et donc les Français nous ont donné un
mandat avec une représentation qui
représente peu au pro l’état politique
du pays et bien ils nous ont donné cet
outil et c'est notre devoir c'est pas
seulement une question de possibilité ou
pas c'est notre
devoirs
selon cette assemblée qu'ils nous ont
donné et donc si on montre
collectivement et ça ça vaut aussi bien
pour nous que pour les oppositions y
compris les plus virulentes qui
cherchent qu'une chose à bloquer le pays
si on leur montre notre incapacité à
gouverner je pense qu'on sera tous
collectivement sanctionné mais on a fait
tout l'inverse jusqu'à présent on a
montré en tout cas notre majorité et des
gros parlementaires disons modérés je
pense notamment aux républicain et à
certains socialistes qu'ensemble on
savait gouverner et ça je pense que
c'est particulièrement vrai à
l'Assemblée c'est aussi vrai au Sénat
le travail qui a été fait peut-être un
peu plus l'habitude aussi de
ces majorités
[Musique]
et en cela je pense qu'il faut aussi
rendre hommage au groupe minoritaire et
au groupe majoritaire est-ce qu'il y a
pas aussi parfois dans la politique
c'est bien normal des postures qu'il
faut que voilà des députés par exemple
du groupe LR dit jamais on ira porter
notre vol à la majorité actuelle et puis
et puis quand ils sont face à leurs
électeurs vous me dit mais pourquoi vous
n'aurez pas vous avez pas voté les
mesures sur le sur le pouvoir d'achat
par exemple ils sont engueuler donc
est-ce qu'il y a pas la posture un peu
politique d'un côté puis au fond la
réalité qui fait que parfois on a
intérêt à voter une loi si elle est
bonne
les députés les républicains se sont
engagés aussi sur un programme sur le
leur vis-à-vis de leurs électeurs
législatives
par exemple sur la question du pouvoir
d'achat l'une des mesures phares qui ont
fait qui est ont voté cette loi et le
projet de loi de finance rectificatif
c'est qu'il s'était engagé à baissé dans
cette Stan station-service le prix de
l'essence a un euro 50
on a trouvé un accord politique entre le
gouvernement la majorité et le groupe
républicain pour faire baisser le prix
de l'essence dans certaines stations
services un euro 50 c'est Victor
politique pour eux et c'est une victoire
politique pour nous parce qu'ils ont
voté avec nous le texte sous pouvoir
d'achat et le PLFR ce fameux projet
d'aide finance rectificatif c'est comme
ça qu'on Bapt idées collision et les
majorités alors sur les postures
chacun d'apprendre ses responsabilités
moi je le vois à l'inverse j'ai assisté
quand même dans les premiers mois de
cette législature à des députés de la
France insoumise qui ont déposer une
proposition de résolution qualifiant
l'État d'Israël des tas d'apartheid
qui compare le jour de la commémoration
de la rafle du Vél' d'hive le président
de la République au maréchal Pétain
qui explique qui dépose des amendements
qui font perdre plusieurs dizaines
minutes de débats
des amendements qui n'ont aucune utilité
sinon sémantique pour créer la polémique
pendant que la France insoumise fait
cela vraiment je pense que chacun va
prendre ses risques vous êtes la France
insoumise parce que c'est eux qui
déposent ces résolutions mais donc dans
le cas de la nupesse moi je me demande
quelle est la position des social ici
sur le sujet on les voit dans
l'assemblée un bon nombre de députés
socialistes avec lequel je partage assez
peu d'idées mais qui sont des députés
d'une opposition modérée moi la question
que je me pose c'est comment est-ce
qu'ils font partie d'un même
inter-groupe que la France insoumise qui
dépose des résolutions des propositions
loi ou qui commentent l'actualité comme
ils le font et comme je vous l'ai décrit
c'est une vraie question que j'ai
et je pense que c'est des clarifications
qui va y avoir lieu dans les mois à
venir justement parler de choses qui
vous surprendre
il y en a un qui était peut-être surpris
qui était un de vos collègues qui est
car le livre qui sait insurgé quand même
contre les méthodes de justement d'un
certain nombre de députés de la nups
des injures de la violence au fond de
ces débats
vous-même ça vous a surpris ou déçu
peut-être de ce que par rapport à l'idée
qu'on peut se faire de ce que une
démocratie il faut moi ce qui m'a
surtout surprise c'est
cette méthode qui
se résigne à faire de la politique sans
résultat
uniquement pour l'image vous restez car
le livre car le livre il a été maire de
Poissy
quand on est maire d'une ville comme
Poissy on est jugé sur des résultats
concrets
on change la vidéo on la change pas et
on la change pour le mieux quand on la
change sinon on se fait sanctionner car
le livre est a été un excellent maire de
Poissy pour cette raison et je pense que
le constat qu'on partage j'ai été
adjoint au maire de la ville de
Versailles c'est quand on travaille pour
le résultat concret sur la vie
quotidienne des gens là ce pouvoir
d'achat on veut des mesures concrètes
pour améliorer leur pouvoir d'achat et
qu'on voit que dans certaines
oppositions pas toutes il y en a
certaines qui ont des oppositions de
fonds fondées sur la position concrète
mais qu'on voit qu'une part des
oppositions les plus extrêmes ont fondé
leur combat sur des postures je
comprends que ça étonne je comprends que
ça étonne des parlementaires qui ont été
maires comme caroleville justement
puisque vous parlez de carolive et il va
faire je crois une proposition de loi
pour revenir contre le non cumul sur le
non-cumul des vendas il dit enfin il y
en a d'autres qui disent au fond
[Musique]
de mandat c'est avoir des députés un peu
hors sol c'est pas mal qu'ils aient une
attache locale etc je crois qu'aurait
berger qui la présente de votre groupe
et pas du tout d'accord avec avec lui là
dessus vous êtes plutôt sur ce point de
vue berger ou olive moi je trouve que
jusqu'à présent on n'a pas encore tout à
fait mesuré les conséquences à la fois
positive certaine comme mesure négatives
sur une telle question la vérité c'est
que le boulot de parlementaire et je me
rends compte aujourd'hui
c'est un boulot 7 jours sur 7 implantant
comme dans d'autres fonctions mais on
est constamment mobilisé tant sur sa
circonscription qu'au niveau national
donc le bleu de député semble à plein
temps
mais je crois l'inverse aussi qui a
certains territoires certaines terres
certaines communes peut-être plus
petites dans des territoires plus ruraux
ou plus éloignés de Paris qui se sentent
moins représentés qu'avant parce que
leur mère on l'a vu parce que leur mère
ne peut plus sécher à l'Assemblée je
trouve que c'est sain comme débat car le
livre fait cette proposition de loi
Aurore berger n'est pas nécessairement
d'accord sur le sujet mais au moins le
débat vit à l'Assemblée y compris dans
le groupe et je crois que la question
mérite d'être posée et vous mentionnez
en berger moi je trouve que on peut
aussi le reconnaître le mérite d'avoir
dirigé un groupe comme elle l'a fait
dans les premiers mois du quinquennat et
du dictature on lui promettait que
jamais on allait réussir à faire passer
nos lois
et on les a fait passer aussi grâce à
notre mobilisation et à ce musée de ce
groupe et grâce aux accords qu'on a pu
trouver avec les oppositions donc sur un
sujet comme ça faut pas avoir peur de
poser le débat alors on va parler de
carolive il y a parmi des élus de
département vous êtes il vous même des
fortes personnalités qui est président
de l'Assemblée aubergé qui est donc
président du groupe on pourrait sauter
un journal barreau qui ministre
c'est c'est facile de se faire un de
faire un trou avec des personnalités qui
sont très fortes à côté de soi c'est
plutôt une aide peut-être en fait moi je
le voyais hyper positivement un parce
que on n'est pas la même génération et
moi ma priorité aujourd'hui
c'est de dédier une immense partie de
mon temps à l'accompagnement des
entreprises des associations et des
citoyens et des élus de ma
circonscription est-ce que le travail
que l'ensemble d'entre eux dans le
centre de ce que vous avez cité on fait
d'abord sont arrivés et puis de deux
c'est quand même une chance pour un
jeune parlementaire de pouvoir
bénéficier l'expérience de gens comme il
y a loin de Pivet
le barreau qui sont présidents de
l'Assemblée nationale ministre président
de groupe les Yvelines aussi
du président du Sénat président du Sénat
aussi c'est une terre sur laquelle il y
a toujours eu de grands élus
délai des élus qui ont occupé des
responsabilités fortes je vous cache pas
qu'en tant que je ne parlementaire c'est
extraordinaire de pouvoir bénéficier de
cette expérience qui nous entoure
justement vous dites parlementaire ce
qui est vrai
est-ce que il y a d'autres jeunes
parlementaires comme quelques-uns en
tout cas qui ont été élus vous avez 25
ans je rappelle
qu'ils sont pas forcément de votre
partie je pense à Louis Boyard qui doit
être le qui est RFI alors pour le coup
est-ce que vous avez des liens est-ce
qu'il y a des liens de justement de
générationnelle entre entre les élus ou
est-ce que
[Musique]
je pense que quand on se voit dans
l'hémicycle et quand on se croise il y a
nécessairement
un partage d'expérience commun elle est
à notre génération il y a notre âge
par contre il est évident que j'ai des
clivage et une opposition tellement
franche opposition que prend Louis
Boyard jour et nuit sur
sur tous les sujets que j'ai pas de
d'habitants particulières avec lui alors
ce que j'entends Louis Boyard dire à la
télévision qu'a police tue je n'ai je ne
me sens absolument pas en lien avec le
billard ou avec tel autre sur le sujet
oui peu importe
je pense que le lien est générationnel
il est certain par contre
les positions comprend
ne nous rapproche pas j'ai relevé
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
politiques dans l'histoire qui était lu
très jeune comme vous il y a Point Carré
il y a modeste France il y a Barnier qui
a été élu très jeune il y a Fillon
Wauquiez aussi
il y en a comme ça qui vous qui sont un
peu des modèles ou
pas Jacques Doriot parce que
[Musique]
c'est une histoire plus tragique j'ai
envie de vous répondre
politique française qui regorge le
personnalité qui sont forcément des
personnages absolument passionnants à
voir une personne qui m'a personnalité
qui m'a particulièrement marqué sur
lequel j'ai lu je pense tout est
biographies qui existent une
personnalité comme Georges Clémenceau
qui est arrivé au pouvoir dans l'une des
périodes peut-être les plus sombres de
notre histoire et c'est extrêmement
inspirant pour des jeunes élus qui
découvrent tout juste la vie politique
de notre pays après de manière plus
concrète moi j'ai un peu de ma tort
depuis que depuis que je me suis engagé
la première c'est François Mazières
maire de Versailles
[Musique]
est extraordinaire et aujourd'hui on a
gardé ce lien très personnel qui fait
que il m'a appris et qu'il continue à
m'apprendre
l'engagement qui est qui est le nôtre en
tant que élu d'un d'une terre élection
la deuxième personne c'est Bruno Le
Maire
personne que j'ai commencé à suivre
depuis la présidence de l'UMP en 2014
puis lors de la primaire
pour lui à ses côtés d'avoir en tant
militants puis en tant que responsable
départemental des Yvelines de sa
campagne primaire puis en tant que
conseiller et enfin aujourd'hui en tant
que parlementaire alors que lui fait
partie numéro 2 du gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est une personnalité qui
qui m'a appris des principes et des
valeurs profondes la principale leçon
qui m'a donné et je me souviens très
bien ma copine la prise c'est que la
principale qualité pour un homme ou une
femme politique et un élu c'est pas la
parole
c'est pas le charisme
c'est l'écoute
il m'a appris qu'il y avait une
différence fondamentale entre entendre
et écouter
et que pour être bon tant mieux
politique il fallait savoir écouter un
pour bien comprendre les besoins chacun
de ces concitoyens mais aussi pour
savoir bien répondre
et que finalement le simple sens de la
parole perdait tout son sens si on
allait pas cette capacité d'écoute avant
et entendre c'est quoi c'est faire
semblant d'écouter non
entendre c'est entendre le bruit écouter
c'est écouter la préoccupation et avoir
été dédiée voilà c'est ça voilà et puis
c'est une personnalité qui est
extrêmement fidèle je l'ai accompagné en
tant que simple militant
et des années après j'ai eu la
possibilité de rejoindre à Bercy à son
cabinet et ensuite pendant ma campagne
législative il est venu au Bistrot du
Boucher à Versailles parler devant une
centaine de personnes pour défendre la
candidature
ça c'est une personne que je qualifie de
fidèle
et qui a été fidèle à mon égard et qui
m'a marqué alors on en parlera pas
aujourd'hui parce qu'on a le temps mais
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui peut avoir un
avenir
qui peut penser un avenir politique mais
c'est vrai que c'est cela dit c'est on
peut en parler une seconde parce que
c'est un des problèmes d'un second
quinquennat c'est que il y a pas de
renouvellement possible du même candidat
c'est à dire on a une certitude c'est
Emmanuel Macron ne sera pas président
dans 5 ans est-ce que ça justement ça
change des choses il y a en effet des
ambitions qui peuvent qui peuvent naître
et c'est bien normal d'ailleurs est-ce
que ça peut changer la façon de de
conduire les affaires
moi je regarde les péripéties qu'on a
connu dans les cinq dernières années
cinq dernières années à l'échelle d'une
république une histoire politique c'est
très court mais à l'échelle d'un mandat
résidentiel et dans le temps politique
c'est incroyablement long
et Bruno Le Maire est la première
personne à dire que c'est juste pas le
moment de penser à la princesse
il est entouré de personnes à mon avis
qui doivent lui poser la question
la réponse est toujours la même pourquoi
parce que
la préoccupation des gens aujourd'hui
c'est pouvoir Achard leur capacité à
consommer à acheter dans une période
comme on l'a connaît aujourd'hui et de
deux c'est parce que je pense que s'il y
en a ceux qui ont des aspérités une
aspiration
occupée d'autres fonctions en 5 ans mais
ils sont tous unis par le même objectif
c'est de réussir ce qu'un cas qui vient
et vous avez raison en 2017 qui serait
douté qu'il allait y avoir les gilets
jaunes la crise du covid et la guerre du
crâne
mais aussi à l'inverse
simultanément un président qui a su
gérer ses crises et si on a un
quinquennat ce que nous ne souhaite pas
oui autant de crises que dans le premier
je suis quand même rassuré qui Emmanuel
Macron était réélu pour tenir la barre
avec cette équipe du gouvernemental
là-dessus et je pense que c'est vraiment
intéressant de voir que nous on est tous
on est tous dédiés à cet objectif là
le lancement du Conseil national de la
refondation des CNR
on voit beaucoup de critiques le
position qui veut pas hyper participer
le président du Sénat qui veut pas y
participer est-ce que au fou ça vous
ça vous interpelle pas parce que on fait
on a l'impression que ces gens-là font
comme s'il y avait pas une crise de la
démocratie or l'abstention est
grandissante les jeunes se détournent de
la politique
est-ce qu'on a pas comme ça la
faussement peut-être que la pression que
la démocratie est là pour toujours et
que c'est un régime qui n'est pas
plutôt l'impression que c'est un régime
plus fragile qu'on ne le pense
alors sur la question spécifique du CNR
et je vous répondrai sur une démocratie
juste après
on sera jugé collectivement sur les
résultats
tout le monde était très sceptique sur
par exemple le grand débat après la
crise gilet jaune le grand débat a donné
les résultats les résultats aujourd'hui
je pense que chacun en garde une image
extrêmement positive parce que ça a été
un grand moment démocratique dans notre
pays
le Conseil national de la Fondation
connu aujourd'hui il lit au même sort
ces résultats moi j'y crois vachement
parce que je pense que un c'est un
engagement de campagne deux on pose des
questions absolument fondamentales pour
les 20 prochaines années qui viennent
donc je trouve que les excellentes mais
on va cibler c'est en fonction des
résultats collectifs pas que de la
majorité de l'opposition la capacité du
gouvernement des parlementaires des
syndicats des partenaires sociaux des
représentants des différentes forces
vives du pays comme le dit Président la
semaine d'accord sur les sujets clés et
on verra ça je pense dans quelques mois
sur la question la démocratie moi je
pense qu'elle est profondément liée à
notre capacité à réfléchir ensemble en
indépendance à ce qu'on veut faire notre
pays
on veut faire quoi de la France
dans les 20 ou 30 prochaines années
est-ce qu'on veut finalement que ça
reste un marché économique
comme certains le conçoivent notamment
dans l'entreprise un pays au milieu d'un
monde qui finalement va de crise en
crise et qui tente de trouver des moyens
d'y répondre
ou est-ce qu'on se dit on est un pays
millénaire
qui a maintenant plus de 2000 ans
d'histoire
qui a surmonté des crises des épreuves
historiques mais comme peu de pays les
ont connu et qui a toujours su par son
identité propre réussite elle est
surmonter
moi c'est ça que je trouve
extraordinaire dans le pays dans lequel
on est et c'est ça qui me rend si ému
d'être parlementaire français
c'est-à-dire qu'on est un pays qui est
pas tout avec je pense que c'est pas peu
dire que de l'exprimer ainsi c'est vrai
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui le fait qu'on
se pose et qu'on se dise très bien on a
bâti ce modèle qui nous a amené à une
démocratie et plus mature au monde on
voit qu'elle en crise la France
et menacée on a une crise économique
énergétique qui affecte directement les
gens
on peut y répondre par des mesures
d'urgence sur les mois qui viennent mais
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire de notre pays
dans les 10 15 50 prochaines années je
trouve ça exceptionnel qu'on est la
capacité de se poser cette question
c'est quand même parce que c'est vrai
forcément quand même à votre place le
nez un peu sur le guidon qu'est-ce qui
se passe demain mais il y a aussi quand
même oui voilà quelle est l'avenir de la
France qu'est-ce que c'est la France
qu'on va laisser vos enfants etc enfin
c'est vraiment des questions
essentielles et il y a un thème sur
lequel d'ailleurs vous avez écrit tout
récemment dans le dans le Figaro c'est
suite d'indépendance culturelle
je vous cite d'ailleurs
la déposition culturelle dont les
Français se sont aujourd'hui des
victimes c'est quoi des possession
culturelles et c'est quoi l'indépendance
culturelle parce que ça aussi c'est un
vrai question de d'identité
je vous remercie de me poser cette
question
on parle tous collectivement d'une sorte
de mal-être dans notre pays notre
mal-être français dans notre société
depuis maintenant peut-être une
vingtaine d'années voire plus
il y en a souvent tendance à dire que la
cause de ce mal-être ce sont les crises
qu'on a connu financière la crise du
covid de la crise du crinière ou de la
crise énergétique mais dans le fond ces
crises la France n'est pas la seule les
avoir connu
une immense majorité des pays de notre
monde et des peuples de notes qui
peuplent de notre monde les ont connu
cette crise quelle est la cause quelle
est la racine du fait que les Français
collectivement se sentent malheureux
dans un pays qui est absolument
magnifique moi je pense que c'est parce
qu'on est un pays qui a été habitué
depuis 2000 ans avoir une culture une
langue un art de vivre extrêmement fort
et que les Français ont le sentiment que
cet art et que cette culture
a tendance un peu à se faiblir un petit
peu s'étioler a tendance à se mêler à
des influences étrangères qui sont pas
nécessairement les nôtres
et dans le monde dans lequel on vit
alors que finalement la puissance d'une
nation on sent aujourd'hui dans le débat
elle se mesure à sa puissance militaire
économique mais elle se mesure aussi à
son rayonnement que les gens
on sent bien que la France malgré tous
nos atouts et menacé en quelque sorte
par des influences étrangères qui ont
une vocation hégémonique
on pourra souvent de la réussite
évidemment
Chine évidemment certains pays du Golfe
ou du Moyen-Orient évidemment mais je
pense qu'il faut aussi le dire les
États-Unis les États-Unis ce sont de
plus proches alliés ils le resteront
mais
je vais vous prendre un exemple très
concret quand vous réveillez le matin
vous allumez votre iPhone que vous allez
sur WhatsApp ou Messenger Facebook
Instagram lorsque vous allez au boulot
vous êtes sur Gmail ou sur Microsoft
vous rentrez chez vous en uber et vous
regardez Netflix le soir en commandant
deliveroo
que des boîtes américaines oui mais
alors justement est-ce que l'Amérique a
pas déjà gagné cette bataille culturelle
je crois c'est vrai pour le cinéma c'est
vrai pour Netflix c'est vrai c'est vrai
qu'on est
si vous prenez la musique aussi enfin
même les gens qui sont qui qui se
veulent très français tout ça ils
écoutent que de la musique américaine
ils vont voir les films américains j'ai
deux certains points de vue la vérité
qui a déjà gagné cette bataille
culturelle on peut on peut résister
encore en fait je la vois pas tant comme
un conflit absolument d'opposition
de dire il y a pas de culture française
et une culture un peu universelle une
culture en France il avait il avait pas
tout à fait tort de dire ça c'est vrai
qu'il faut il faut aussi amasser les
autres cultures enfin les les les
intégrer moi je crois fondamentalement
qu'il y a une culture française
d'ailleurs le président Macron la
qualifié ainsi une culture dans le pays
une culture française qu'on ressent tous
lorsqu'on demande à chacun des Français
dans la rue est-ce que la France a une
culture évidemment oui mais elle est
très difficile à définir tout simplement
parce qu'elle est vivante et on a des
atouts clés et simplement il faut
définir des lignes rouges sur certains
sujets évidemment que ça serait
complètement caricatural de dire que
pour sauver notre culture il faut qu'on
arrête d'utiliser Google absolument pas
golf et vivre des dizaines d'entreprises
[Musique]
c'est qu'on a chacun un rôle à jouer le
plus petit des rôles qu'on peut jouer
c'est évacuer les anglicismes moi le
premier j'ai tout le temps hello le
premier c'est d'éliminer les
anglaiscismes de notre langage on a une
langue que le monde nous envie qui est
parlé par plus d'un milliard d'habitants
dans ce monde faisons la vivre et c'est
vrai donc nous on a un rôle à jouer les
entreprises ont un rôle à jouer
aujourd'hui le chef d'entreprise il est
encore on verra il est encore le choix
et ce qui l'accepte que les chantres du
wokisme prennent le pouvoir dans leurs
entreprises ou est-ce qu'ils préfèrent
faire rayonner le capitalisme social et
économique qui a toujours fait la
richesse notre tissu économique en
France et en Europe il a un choix
stratégique à faire et enfin
avant toute chose une question volonté
politique
si on veut faire rayonner notre culture
et qu'on voit qu'aujourd'hui par exemple
les gafam
les géants du numérique sont les
cavaliers des cultures étrangères dans
notre pays et bien il faut les réguler
le gouvernement a gagné des victoires
politiques majeurs sur le sujet
n'hésitez pas à taxé à la hauteur des
revenus qui créent en France aujourd'hui
les gars femme sont taxées à la hauteur
des revenus qui génèrent en France et
une époque où segafam c'est géant du
numérique
gérer nos données ou abriter nos données
sans règles et en faisait une unité
commerciale comme une autre grâce aux
normes qui s'appelle les normes rgpd qui
vont être renforcés par les tous les
réglementations qu'on appelle DSA DMA
nos données vont être beaucoup mieux
gérés pour notre propre protection la
protection des citoyens français et
européens il faut qu'on aille encore
plus loin sur ces sujets
toutes ces plateformes enfin une étape
européenne quand même on a laissé un peu
les États-Unis faire tout seul non là
dessus moi quand je vois des entreprises
comme OVH
moi j'estime qu'on a pas perdu cette
bataille non elle est peut-être pas
perdue
aujourd'hui
l'un des principaux sujets là-dessus
c'est développé notre capacité de
financement pour soutenir ces
entreprises dans leur croissance puis 5
ans il y a des dizaines et dizaines et
même avant des centaines d'entreprises
qui sont des pépites technologiques qui
ont été soutenus financièrement et qui
sont en train de grandir on parle de
licornes qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
licorne ce sont des startups qui
aujourd'hui valent plus d'un milliard
d'euros aujourd'hui on a des dizaines et
des dizaines et des dizaines dans notre
pays notamment des licornes numériques
il faut continuer à les soutenir il faut
maintenant aller encore plus loin et le
prochain combat ça va être le met à
l'aise mais derrière c'est un mot qui
fait peur ça motivé
dans un moment de notre société où il va
y avoir un monde nouveau qui va arriver
qu'on perçoit pas bien du mal à capter
en fait pour moi c'est un monde
parallèle le métabolisme c'est un monde
qui va être qui va être placé dans le
virtuel mais il va avoir une capacité du
fait des sensations de vivre qui aura
une influence influence en réalité
c'est un sujet qui est ni bon ni mauvais
c'est juste l'usage qu'on en fait et qui
contrôle cette usage l'Europe et la
croisée des chemins soit on développe
ses capacités numériques européennes et
on a les capacités de rester autonome
souverain
soit on laisse ses capacités numériques
et financières à des puissances comme
les américains les Chinois et dans ce
cas là l'Europe ne pourra pas dire au
milieu du siècle qu'elle est souveraine
et qu'elle autonome moi je pense
vraiment d'avoir un discours comme ça
parce que on l'entend relativement peu
c'est vrai que je suis assez frappé par
le fait que sur l'intelligence
artificielle sur l'homme augmenté sur le
métabolaire
la classe politique nous paraît assez
silencieuse alors que alors que ce sont
les problèmes de d'aujourd'hui déjà
il y a peut-être une question de
générationnelle peut-être
et puis la deuxième je pense qu'il faut
juste partir de principe simple
je crois vraiment que le 21e siècle sera
un siècle qui serait structuré autour de
la compétition entre les Etats-Unis et
la Chine de géants démographiques
économiques financiers politiques
technologiques
les pays européens ont le choix soit ils
forment une troisième puissance
démographique économique technologique
chaque pays gardera son indépendance on
sera jamais empire unique mais
simplement c'est de dire qu'on accepte
de mettre quelques compétences en commun
pour conserver chacun notre souveraineté
et notre liberté soit on le fait pas
et je pense qu'un deuxième principe qui
rayonnera au 21e siècle c'est qu'on
n'aura jamais d'indépendance ou de
souveraineté politique sans indépendance
ou de souveraineté technologique les
deux sont intimement corrélés et donc
pour garder notre souveraineté politique
et bien il faut qu'on acquérisse notre
souveraineté technologique c'est ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui avec les
batteries l'Europe a relancé massivement
sa production de batterie grâce à
l'initiative commune du président de la
République en France et l'Allemagne
pareil dans les semi-conducteurs les
compenses électroniques concrètement
qu'on trouve dans nos voitures dans nos
avions dans nos hélicoptères dans nos
téléphones on le fait sur le spatial il
va je pense qu'il faut vraiment aussi le
faire sur toutes les technologies
numériques qui existent
un mot sur deux problèmes qui concerne
votre circonscription sur laquelle vous
êtes intervenu le premier c'est
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
qui va qui va se fondre avec celle de
Saclay
vous vous plaidez pour que au fond
il y a encore des établissements qui
restent dans les Yvelines c'est ça alors
en fait que tout n'aille pas sur le
plateau de sa clé ou le premier sujet
c'est que je trouve qu'il est il était
vital et c'est une excellente nouvelle
que l'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines soit membre et
fasse partie intégrante de l'université
Paris-Saclay
extraordinaire d'excellence c'est la
première université non-américaine au
monde
sur des dizaines et des dizaines de
matières et l'université vers 150 ans en
Yvelines en rejoignant l'Université
Paris Saclay et bien avec toutes ces
richesses ces entreprises ces ingénieurs
ces étudiants rejoint ce pôle
d'excellence mais pour moi notamment
avec le développement d'un structure
clés comme la ligne 18 et comme d'autres
l'université vers sa Saint-Quentin
Yvelines peut tout à fait pas faire
partie de l'université Paris-Saclay en
conservant ces infrastructures sur le
bassin Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et le
sujet dont je vais particulièrement
évoqué cet été en cette rentrée c'est la
Faculté de Médecine cette faculté de
médecine a Monte basé à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux c'est une faculté
qui est assez extraordinaire parce que
elle est fondée elle n'est pas liée
intimement un siège
donc ce qui lui permet à la fois
d'expérimenter un certain nombre de de
projets assez extraordinaires et puis en
plus qui permet d'alimenter une bonne
partie des hôpitaux du département je
pense notamment à celui de Poissy et
celui de plaisir ou à celui de l'hôpital
milieux de Versailles ou l'hôpital Foch
et d'autres c'est une faculté de
médecine qui a développé une expertise
dans un certain nombre de sujets
absolument clé qui alimente en formant
nos étudiants toutes les structures
médicales médico-sociales et
hospitalières dans le département
notamment dans ce bassin et qui en plus
est devenu un centre clé technologique
de biotech qui sont installés dans les
zones d'activité qu'il y a autour de la
faculté la délocalisation de la faculté
serait pour nous une catastrophe
d'accord mais aujourd'hui ce qui me
rassure c'est que la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche qui était l'ancienne cuisine
c'est engagé à ce que cette faculté
reste à Montigny Bretonneux et puisse
continuer à développer ses activités sur
place donc ça c'est le sujet je me suis
emparé politiquement tout simplement
c'est tout simplement pour confirmer
cette tendance confirmer ses décisions
et confirmer que tout en étant parti
intégrante de l'université Versailles de
Paris Saclay pardon l'UVSQ est plus
principalement la Faculté de Médecine
restez bien sur ses bases en
l'occurrence à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
deuxième sujet sur lequel vous êtes
intéressé un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui sont des entreprises
assez innovantes notamment vers Montigny
qui n'arrivent pas à trouver
preneur comment on explique ça c'est
vrai que c'est un phénomène on parle de
la grande démission peut-être qu'il y a
un nouveau rapport des aides au monde du
travail mais comment on explique ça
comme parce qu'elles sont c'est pas des
emplois de base c'est des emplois
intéressants tout à fait ingénieur etc
c'est des emplois très qualifiés
et donc ce sont des emplois pérennes et
bien payé
ça d'ailleurs fait l'objet de ma
première question gouvernement un moment
émouvant pour moi
tout le paradoxe qu'on connaît dans ce
pays c'est quelle heure qu'il y a des
entreprises qui recrutent et qui sont en
mal de recruter
il y a toute une partie de notre
jeunesse qui quitte la France
l'immigration d'une partie de notre
jeunesse hors de notre pays parce
qu'elle ne trouve pas de quoi travailler
ici
c'est quand même un tout un paradoxe qui
existe aujourd'hui qui est un paradoxe
qui a commencé à être résolu par deux
choses un la réforme d'une bonne partie
de filière d'apprentissage dans le pays
plus le développement des contrat
d'apprentissage qui ont permis en
l'espace de cinq ans sur le premier
quinquennat de passer de 250 000 après
ce que 800 000 apprentis par an une
réussite qu'on a peu connue dans ce pays
il fallait plus loin quand le président
de la République s'engage sur la réforme
du lycée professionnel parce que lorsque
vous interrogez les entreprises qui sont
le plus en pénurie de recrutement ce
sont des entreprises qui cherchent
souvent deux types de profil soit de
l'ingénierie scientifique de pointe soit
des métiers très techniques qui
demandent moins d'années d'études mais
qui demande une spécificité clé
la menuiserie de l'Industrielle la
chaudronnerie les thieuiers
les pâtissiers les bouchers
qui sont en fait qui sont en plus au
cœur du savoir-vivre de l'art de vivre à
la française
exactement et bien aujourd'hui si vous
avez des entreprises qui demandent à
recruter dans ces domaines que vous avez
des jeunes qui sont de plus en plus
passionnés par ces métiers mais qui
n'arrivent pas se faire embaucher et
même le maillon du milieu c'est le lycée
professionnel et s'il est filières
d'enseignement supérieur d'apprentissage
qui suit c'est une des réformes clés à
mener pendant ce quinquennat je vous
cache pas que c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle je suis sûr aussi fier de faire
passer cette majorité cette
participation pour chez nous et puis
plus plus spécifiquement pour les
questions locales de notre
circonscription
aujourd'hui les communes sont en demande
d'autonomie de gestion et d'autonomie
financière moi je crois que
fondamentalement puisque concrètement
les entreprises lorsqu'elles viennent
s'installer dans une commune elle paye
des impôts à la commune l'une des clés
pour permettre à une commune d'acroix de
son autonomie financière c'est d'attirer
des entreprises donc moi je travaille
quotidiennement avec les trois mères de
ma circonscription
Laurent mercker mère de mon Bretonneux
et François Morton maire de Guyancourt
l'un des sujets sur lesquels vraiment
j'ai insisté auprès d'eux et auquel je
trouve d'ailleurs un écho qui est qui
est très positif c'est que je me vois
vraiment comme un ambassadeur de ne pas
circonscription des trois communes de
matières conscription pour continuer
d'attirer des entreprises c'est une
ville comme Montigny-le-Bretonneux un
service public aussi fort aussi
important auprès de ses habitants
qui fait la richesse
c'est aussi parce qu'il y a des
entreprises qui sont installées qui ont
créé des emplois qui participent à la
vie de la ville et qui paye des impôts
auprès de la commune qui permet de
financer ses services c'est par exemple
laquelle vraiment je défends cette ligne
quelques mots peut-être un peu sur vous
on parlez de la langue française tout à
l'heure de la défense que vous faites de
la France mais vous vous êtes totalement
bilingue totalement voilà mon père est
anglaise j'ai grandi une grande partie
de ma vie en France notamment je suis
arrivé dans les Yvelines à Versailles à
l'âge de 7 ans donc je me sens
évidemment principalement et
passionnément imprégné de la culture
française mais c'est vrai que le fait
d'avoir connu une double culture c'est
une richesse personnelle à laquelle je
suis très attaché mais c'est ce qui
permet aussi de voir à quel point ce
sont deux pays différents à quel point
le modèle français est unique faudrait
quand même qu'on fasse aussi quelques
efforts pour parler un peu mieux
française
justement Versailles oui vous avez vécu
l'âge de 7 ans même si vous avez
d'autres
d'autres habitations avant de lui vous
avez habité après
on se fait peut-être pas assez qu'elle
était à la fois historique et
extrêmement novatrice notamment en
matière de musique on va dire d'art
enfin
c'est une ville de paradoxe et c'est ça
que j'aime avec cette ville c'est que
c'est une ville qui est ancrée dans
l'histoire
c'est une ville qui
mentionne beaucoup le château de
Versailles mais c'est une ville qui a
connu une histoire absolument
exceptionnelle tant on peut parler du
château mais on peut parler du jeu de la
salle du Jeu de paume et tout ce qui est
connu on peut parler des inventions de
Pierre et Marie Curie qui ont lieu à 300
mètres de la mairie mais c'est aussi une
ville qui a toujours eu la capacité à
faire naître des ruptures technologiques
politiques sociales et on mentionne
Révolution française dans Versailles
l'un des berceaux monsieur les
inventions de Pierre et Marie Curie on
peut mentionner aujourd'hui toute la
réflexion qui a derrière ça dans le
mieux vivre dans le bien-être dans la
manière et françois de Mazières y est
pour beaucoup dans la manière dans la
manière de mettre la politique
urbanistique la politique patrimoniale
d'une ville au service du bien-être des
gens de ce point de vue là c'est une
ville extrêmement moderne et quand vous
allez à Versailles on voit que c'est une
ville qui est beaucoup plus diverses
aussi culturellement et socialement
absolument
de modernité et beaucoup d'inventivité
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'étais
passionnément engagé là-bas élu et c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'y vis toujours
aussi vous avez un bistro préféré
j'en ai mais je vais me faire des jeunes
mais je pense que les préférés le savent
de qui je parle
bien
l'ambition ou la fibre en politique
c'est venu très tôt chez vous très tôt
évidemment vous êtes
vous aviez quoi 21 ou 22 ans et député
25 ans c'est ça mais bon mais quand
est-ce que vous vivez pensez comme ça la
première fois en fait c'est difficile
pour moi de répondre il y a plein de
gens qui vous donneront un mot clé ils
ont eu une sorte de vocation qui est
apparue une réunion publique une
interview regardait à la télévision ou
autre
la chance que j'ai eu dans ma jeunesse
c'est que j'ai toujours une famille sans
avoir été élu je pense que je crois que
je suis le premier élu de ma famille
mais c'est une famille qui a toujours
été politique politisée on a toujours
connu énormément parler de débats à
table c'est une fille qui est née assez
jeune chez moi parce que tant dans mon
cercle familial proche que l'on a fait
élargi on a toujours eu des débats
politiques très ennemis et assez profond
ce qui m'a toujours beaucoup touché et
puis après c'est venu petit à petit j'ai
ces moments un peu clés qui donc je me
souviens
associatif où j'ai rencontré François
Mazières maire de Versailles et ses élus
de l'époque qui étaient très engagés
cette première campagne politique en
2014 auprès de Bruno Le Maire qui qui
m'a beaucoup marqué c'est apprentissage
du rôle parlementaire auprès de Franck
Riester parce qu'à l'époque je
travaillais avec lui ici à l'Assemblée
nationale mais aussi dans sa
circonscription
[Musique]
très très belle terre également et c'est
vraiment des moments
progressifs où je me suis dit que
au-delà de la deuxième grande passion
dans la vie qui sont une partie des
cultures et des histoires de pays
africains j'ai vécu à travailler au
Maroc j'ai vécu et travailler en Côte
d'Ivoire
je crois que cet engagement cette fibre
politique elle est venue au fur et à
mesure les expériences que j'ai connues
et le moins de plaisir c'est
qu'aujourd'hui je regrette absolument
pas
j'ai vu que pour vous décrire comme ça
le truc qui m'a faire rire
une gueule d'ange sur un corps de
rugbyman ça vous convient quand j'ai lu
cet article je t'ai pas tout seul quand
je l'ai découvert et je peux vous dire
que j'ai rougi oh j'ai fait ça leur
rugby c'est une passion que j'ai et puis
toujours
j'ai joué voilà au Rugby Club de
Versailles au Stade Français à Paris
deuxième et troisième ligne j'étais je
pense pouvoir dire que j'étais un bon
placard j'ai toujours beaucoup aimé
plaqué
en défense pas trop mais en fait
vraiment je j'ai toujours beaucoup
beaucoup aimé la défense dans ce sport
et c'est un sport qui est à la fois très
physique mais aussi très faut réfléchir
en permanence dans son positionnement
dans la stratégie à déployer et ça c'est
et puis surtout un esprit une équipe qui
moi m'a beaucoup marqué donc
cette citation j'avoue sur le moment et
il m'a fait plaisir pas mal voilà c'est
quand même pas mal pour conclure
peut-être ça va pas si la situation est
difficile évidemment la situation du
pays enfin au moment où vous êtes élu et
ça vous appelle cette cette phrase de
Michel Rocard quand j'ai été nommé pour
le ministre qui a dit enfin les enduits
commencent est-ce que vous voyez
apprendre à votre compte je pense que si
vous dites ça à n'importe quel président
n'importe quel ministre je pense qu'il
vous répondrai qu'en fait les ennuis
n'ont jamais cessé c'est vrai et en fait
c'est ça que je trouve passionnant dans
ne serait-ce que dans un rôle plus
modeste de de parlementaire quoi le
passionnant mais c'est la conjugaison
permanente entre les faits l'actualité
qu'on anticipe pas qui sont souvent des
ennuis
et en même temps replacer la gestion de
ces faits dans une vision ou dans un
mouvement de plus long terme vers une
direction et c'est la conjugaison des
deux qui est souvent impossible qui est
absolument passionnant dans un rôle
d'élus ou dans un rôle politique et je
pense je pense en tout cas que c'est ce
que dirait n'importe quel élu qui soit
de mon camp de mon parti ou d'un parti
opposé au bien c'est de là dans ton tir
une passion pour la vie politique merci
charles-aude merci à vous merci d'être
venu dans mon bureau à l'Assemblée
nationale merci
[Musique]